- Quand tu te sens prête,
Roxane, tu entres dans
le labyrinthe.
- Ciboire, juste là,
j'ai de la misère à rentrer.
- Que l'on soit claustrophobe
ou non, plonger dans
cet étroit labyrinthe
peut devenir angoissant.
Si Roxane accepte de relever
le défi, c'est qu'elle est ici
pour apprendre à mieux
gérer son stress.
- Est-ce que là, tu sens que ton
intensité de stress a augmenté?
- Oui.
- Tu es à combien, sur ton...?
- 140!
- OK. Tu vois, là, ton visage
est devenu plus rouge. C'est
quoi tes pensées présentement?
- C'est que j'ai l'air
d'une ostie d'épaisse en train
de se tortiller entre
les barreaux, là!
- OK.
JONATHAN BLUTEAU psychoéducateur
prof. Dép. d'éducation, UQAM
- Oui, ça peut paraître très
impressionnant, mais on ne force
jamais un jeune. On lui propose
des défis. Et après, on voit
comment il réagit.
- Jonathan Bluteau a créé
le programme In vivo avec
le Centre jeunesse de
Lanaudière, maintenant appelé
le Centre intégré de santé
et services sociaux.
- C'est vraiment un programme
d'entraînement à développer
des nouvelles compétences
pour faire face à des situations
stressantes, qui sont des
situations de la vie courante.
- Comme Roxane a été prise
en charge par la DPJ,
vous ne verrez pas son visage.
Mais puisqu'une caméra a été
fixée sur sa tête, c'est
de son point de vue que
nous vivons l'expérience.
- Applique ta respiration
abdominale.
- Lorsqu'on stresse un individu,
on voit ses traits
tempéramentaux apparaître.
Dans le cas de Roxane,
c'est une jeune fille qui peut
manifester de l'anxiété, mais
ça va aussi se manifester par
des comportement plus activés
ou agressifs ou de colère.
- L'entraîneure aide Roxane
à reconnaître les signes
de stress et surtout,
à trouver la bonne stratégie
pour y faire face.
(petit rire)
- Là je suis pognée.
- OK.
- J'aurais besoin d'aide.
On peut-tu enlever un...
- Quel style de stratégie
tu prends présentement?
- Je demande de l'aide.
- Lequel tu voudrais
que j'enlève?
- Celui là.
- OK.
- Demander de l'aide, on l'a vu
avec Roxane, aujourd'hui,
demander de l'aide, c'est
une stratégie favorable.
Mais certains jeunes utiliser
des stratégies de repli sur soi,
ne s'affirmeront pas. Donc là,
ça peut mener, dans la vie,
réelle là, dans la vie réelle,
ça peut mener à des problèmes,
si je m'affirme pas, si je suis
pas capable de dire à quelqu'un:
non je n'aime pas ça.
- Sortez-moi de là!
- Ça a changé la perception que
tu avais par rapport au stress?
- C'est sûr que ma perception a
changé, parce que dans le fond,
moi, j'avais une spirale
négative. Dans le fond,
je nourrissais moi-même
mon propre stress. Donc,
il prenait de l'ampleur.
Mais c'est sûr que ça aide
à trouver des moyens afin
de le gérer, puis tout, là.
- Sa travailleuse sociale estime
que Roxane gère aujourd'hui
beaucoup mieux ses émotions.
MYRIAM DESJARDINS, technicienne
travail social, CISSS Lanaudière
- Elle va être capable
de rationaliser. Avant,
c'était juste de l'émotif.
Là, elle est capable de
comprendre d'où la situation
vient. Donc, bon, son copain a
fait telle chose, c'est venu
la bouleverser, elle est capable
d'identifier une stratégie
maintenant pour faire face
et trouver une solution.
- Bon, OK Roxane, on est rendu
à l'escalade. Présentement,
tu es à combien sur ton
cardiofréquencemètre?
- 125.
- 125. Au repos, t'es à combien
normalement?
- 52.
- T'es prête?
- Oui.
CLAUDE JULIEN, tech., éducation
spécialisée, CISSS de Lanaudière
- Roxane est habituée de faire
de l'escalade, elle aime ça,
et elle a de bonnes compétences.
De hausser la demande,
de hausser le défi pour Roxane,
pour ce qui est d'aujourd'hui,
c'était tout simplement de lui
donner l'occasion d'avoir
un petit peu plus de malaise
pour voir apparaître tout
simplement ses signes de stress,
pour qu'elle soit en mesure de
mieux s'adapter, même si le défi
est plus grand pour elle.
À partir de maintenant, tu as
le droit seulement aux verts.
As-tu un problème?
- Oui, je peux-tu mettre
mon pied sur le bleu?
- Lequel?
- Celui-là!
- Celui à gauche en haut.
- Lui là-bas?!
- Oui.
- T'es-tu sérieux...
- On sait que de bien gérer
le stress est un facteur
protecteur pour la santé mentale
et les problèmes de
comportement. Ça fait qu'il y a
une logique théorique derrière
le programme, mais maintenant
on se rend compte qu'on
développe d'autres choses.
On sait qu'on travaille
l'affirmation de soi.
Ce n'était pas quelque chose
qui était prévu au départ.
- Bon, là je ne suis pas capable
d'aller sur le losange.
Plus de lousse, je pense.
- Plus?
- Oui.
- Le programme In vivo a été
déployé dans trois centre
jeunesses et trois commissions
scolaires, en plus d'être
pratiqué en France.
- Le fait qu'on ait percé
en France, pour nous c'est
encourageant. Ça montre que
ça répond à un besoin
d'intervention, autant pour
les institutions que pour
les intervenants, puis pour
les adolescents.
- Une façon à la fois ludique
et concrète d'aider les jeunes
à faire face au stress.
- Ouf!
- Bravo! Bravo!
- Ici Vincent Maisonneuve,
Radio-Canada, Joliette.